thank you thank you everybody flora for
being here everybody who is who is
physically here and then made it to
actually the lecture hall and then
everybody who's who's watching from far
away I've I figured out after many years
that I kind of learned a lot about
technology over the years but I was
struggling where conflicts that arose
from technology and so I thought in
order to learn more about it and maybe
improve my my understanding and and
unskillful activities on that front the
best way to do it is to try to give a
talk and see if that can teach me
something so if you look at the talk
from from the perspective of often
attempt to to learn more about the
subject it may explain some of the
things that that are in there so so in
order to start I really need to start
way back because this is this is also
the picture up on on the talk
announcement this is really the guy
who's got me here
it's me from 1982 which is when I
decided that that computers are cool and
I would like to build the world's
fastest computers and that kind of set
me off on a journey that that was very
interesting and continues to be
interesting now but I thought to give
some credit to to the person who got me
here because it's a completely different
person from from me today although we
share we share one thing which is we we
both really enjoy doing assembly
programming and so this is this is how
it all started and just today I had the
tremendous honor to to meet somebody who
was part of the zilog team that built
the Zilog
dat that was in that computer so that's
kind of it was a surprise for me this
morning
so this is how it all started with with
sexual instructions
some of them had to be hand coded of
course and had to translate these things
into zeros and ones and then then feed
it into memory by hand so that it would
go in there was a bit tedious but it did
pay off because it led to an amazing III
80 lecture that I gave some some years
after that so so the next step I'm
fast-forwarding here obviously there
were a few steps in between but this is
mm and the one where I gave a talk here
at the e3 80s seminar on on this crazy
idea I had where you could build faster
computer than anything else you could
build the world's fastest computers out
of these chips called FPGAs and there's
a lot of credit to a lot of people who
have of course helped and then
influenced that many of which are also
in this audience here but the idea was
was not the whole thing
there was the second part which is to
actually make it happen going from the
idea that something is possible to
actually deliver a complete working
system in production in a place that is
using it and and measurably benefits
from having that speed and that that
activity happen in a different computing
environment then then the world is used
to so this was the talk and and I'm not
going to go through all of it but it
basically said FPGAs can outperform
micro processors on certain tasks by
many orders of magnitude that was kind
of the premise I kind of thought yes I
think that that should be possible was a
big leap because it was not clear that
it it can be done but it looked like it
should be possible and and they were
people like Dennis Allison of course
Martin morph and and others who were
encouraging me in that direction saying
it should be
possible so after that the next step
this is again a few years later you go
one decade on I'm really fast
fast-forwarding here there was a credit
crisis and during the credit crisis who
wanted to come
credit derivatives and so we had
JPMorgan the largest bank in in the
Western world
come here to Stanford to give a talk at
a III eighty exactly ten years after the
first one and they were talking about
the deployment of a machine built by the
company I started to do this which was
computing scenarios of risk calculation
what could happen in the future so that
they can balance their their portfolios
and make sure the whole thing doesn't go
under at the time this was publicized as
reducing their compute time from eight
hours down to two minutes so it made the
real operational difference instead of
waiting all night to get the computation
done they were saying now we can run it
in the afternoon now of course the
people who were running the data center
that was running all night they were not
happy at all
because the petition was supposed to run
all night and they were supposed to take
care of it and if it can be done in two
minutes in in the afternoon there is
really nothing for them to do all night
watching the computers to do something
so what I didn't expect at this point
was that anybody would have a problem
with that it seemed to me as if the
problem was there I've solved the
problem everybody should be happy and
yet a lot of people were extremely
unhappy and that that came as a surprise
and it took many many years for me to
catch up with that surprise that I've
done my homework I've submitted my
answer the answer was correct it was
accepted as working everything's good I
get a good grade and and and get a
degree but no no in this case that
didn't happen and so that's what led me
onto this new journey of of what happens
when you actually do these things now we
were pushing it a little bit further
after
saying no what's the hardest thing you
could possibly do well for 9-month aught
that weather prediction is the hardest
thing and he dedicated many many years
of his life to to weather prediction and
climate and and just thought that was
the hardest thing you can do so have a
climate model implemented here we said
well we wouldn't do it ourselves let
somebody else do it
so this was done over at Shanghai
University in China by students there
and they used our infrastructure and the
machine that that they got from us and
they they compared it of course to the
world's fastest supercomputer that that
existed in China at the time and the
result is here published in in the paper
in 2013 it showed that it was running 14
times faster so the first big take
people make you say no no you mean 14%
faster no it's not 14% faster it is 14
times faster so how can it be the
fastest computer in the world
how can it be 14 times faster than the
fastest computer in the top number one
computer in the supercomputing list well
the answer is very simple we were
measuring the speed you can attain in a
fixed amount of space and with a fixed
amount of energy and apparently that's
not how you put your computers you
measure computers by saying who has the
most money to buy the most computers to
stick into the room and then you say
whoever's got more he has the fastest
computer in the world so if you've got
more money you can buy more computers
and then you get to the top of the list
any other kind of measurement apparently
is not not a valid measurement that's
not not the right way to do it that's
how we could do it by simply changing
the the metric changing the way we're
measuring thought you know it should be
really computations per what that that
should matter and NVC of course per watt
energy improvement is only 9x because
there is some inefficiencies of course
in translating speed to to power but we
thought that that was quite good and
there was a machine here that that we
built as a picture
of an actual Mac seller computer
standing in a data center next to an IBM
Blue Gene and there's another picture
there of getting some attention on on
the world stage in terms of doing
something that seems to be print from
from what anybody else is doing so that
was great what was the next thing we say
okay fine we need more applications you
need to have applications to run on
these computers so the European Union
funded a project where reported four of
the top applications in HPC to to this
new machine model and paradigm and so we
implemented starting bottom-up or fake
simulation it's quite quite important
for people quantum espresso is is a
chemistry simulation that takes a very
long time Nemo is ocean modeling very
important to figure out how the currents
are are flowing and then what's
happening in the in the ocean especially
now with global warming and the impact
of climate and oceans and all of that
and then the one at the top which is my
favorite one which is quantum
chromodynamics simulating the forces
inside of the basic particles that form
that put the quarks together into the
actual basic particles so it's
simulating quirks interacting with each
other possibly the world's hardest
simulation you can do because that's at
the bottom of the of the food chain any
system you want to simulate will have
the most quarks
regardless of what else is in there and
they showed some some speed-up depending
on how much effort we could put into
that but again multiple times of
performance that the competing systems
would ruin and each time there's a
different type of computer that they
told us they're currently running it on
so we're comparing it to the machine
that was actually used as a scientist
that they picked for that kind of
problem there is a Trapster of blue blue
jean blue jean q there was a comparison
to the cray XE 30 another blue
Jeanne and and the curry cluster which
is just just regular CPU nodes like x86
so so then let's look at a broader
impact of what has this done to to our
suppliers so we buy chips from from a
company Kansai links they make the FPGAs
and these have been picking up in the
data center space in in computing quite
a bit we can see here what what happened
first
III 80 talk was just after the bump of
of 2000 I started Mac seller when when
the talk of Xilinx was quite quite at
the low level and not much happened
really until point we had Intel by the
main competitor of Xilinx which was
altaira and they paid a lot of money for
it that gave a huge boost to to the
whole concept of computing with with
FPGAs and then at some point later we
had a new CEO at Xilinx and he announced
a data center first strategy on Wall
Street which was the direction that the
company was going to go from then on and
the stock price really really kind of
took off from there with a little bump
at the end where the u.s. decided to
suggest they would limit the sale of
certain technologies to China and that
that caused a dip in expectations of
what that would be because FPGAs may
have been one of these technologies that
could have been limited to be sold to
China so so this is called as as a
development from saying in 2000 but
certainly even in China there was more
focus on on one organization in
particular I believe that was in
particular in the crosshairs of the
government about probably most of them
so so the biggest percentage of sales of
these chips go to Iowa and then is the
rest
yes Denver is the supercomputing
conference which I have been avoiding
successfully for the last few decades
there is there is yeah that's that's a
good topic for for the dinner maybe
maybe not so relevant for the talk but
apps absolutely absolutely know so so
let's step out of this and see another
slide very interesting from the CEO of
Mentor Graphics one of the leading US
companies in silicon software tools this
is a slide from from Wally Rhines from
from a public slide deck that is on the
internet and so I thought this is
particularly interesting it says that
that there is 2.8 times the investment
into silicon technologies in China a
fabless fabless silicon technologies
compared to the US and that is spoken by
the CEO of the US company that just got
bought by Siemens which is a German
company I am not aware of any
limitations on software sales ok ok well
I'm not as I said this is not my my
expertise so I yes happy - yeah there
may be some things don't know so so then
at that point that that kind of brought
me to the idea of really it's it's about
conflict and and how these conflicts are
managed and I got here this little quote
which I thought was quite quite telling
where force persisted through a series
of conflicts then vanished is not not a
bank but but we have in Paris the
economic and social environment change
the new problems in the new series of
force suggesting a cycle suggesting a
cycle of conflicts and that of course is
from Isaac Asimov what I didn't know and
and Dennis kindly taught me that this
morning is that it comes from Isaac
Asimov quoting TS Eliot so it has a
longer history of where it is coming
from so so then that brought me to to
the conflicts and you say okay where do
we start well if we start with the
conflict between between US and China
you then have other more mundane
conflicts between chip technologies as
we've seen in the industry conflicts
between CPUs GPUs FPGAs which one's the
right one
which one's the better one which one
should you use all of these discussions
then there is a conflict between VHDL
people or very long people people who
write hardware circuitry in in RTL and
in high-level synthesis people people
who like to use higher-level languages
higher level things to generate these
that has been a conflict going on for
decades very very harsh conflict maybe
even harsher the ones above it then
there's between software people and
hardware people software people would
say that everything should be done in
software hardware people say yes but I
can build one that's much better than
than the previous so there's always two
different perspectives in in the
commercial world you don't have
conflicts between internal and external
where you come and you want to actually
deliver a technology to a large
corporation there is always a team in
that large corporation it already has
the job to do that and it becomes very
difficult to convince them that as an
external group you bring that into that
organization especially for a small
supplier there is nothing in it for them
if you're a big supplier buying
something from a big supplier is always
very good for
those years while buying something from
a small supplier that that's a problem
for for social and economic environments
then in the banking environment one of
the things that we realized with working
with with financial institutions is the
discrepancy of expectations between
people who are trading and running P and
LS and and making the money and then the
back-office IT people the people who run
the machines behind them and that's an
internal thing that is happening in
these organizations but working with
them one finds itself either on the one
side or on the other side you cannot
have to pick sides enough about I don't
want to pick sides I'm not interested in
that than just I just built this
computer it runs fast I can enjoy that
but but that's not possible so so you
get dragged into these existing
conflicts if you want to you don't
there's of course always conflicts
between employees and and and management
and then you can easily check my the
comments about myself on Glassdoor to to
get a good feeling about me and and what
I'm doing there are particularly
entertaining so I really encourage
everybody to do that there's small and
large companies obviously there is the
not invented here syndrome they changed
you to two new products inertia all of
these good things but most importantly
and something that I found fascinating
is there is this conflict between old
conflicts and new conflicts you have
things that have been a conflict for a
long time been around but then the
newcomer thinks that beginning no
existing thinks that that just came up
and you get you get surprised by saying
oh yeah another one like like populism I
I keep trying to tell people I didn't
know they were populism ten years ago I
didn't use that nobody used it it's a
new thing and and suddenly it's a
problem because they're the people who
are against populism and the ones were
for populism and we didn't have that I
don't remember a problem with populism
before there is a new problem where we
now believe that the internet is bad for
democracy there's all these ways where
the Internet can be used to to influence
it and change things and an impact
elections I'm not aware of that problem
existing 30 years ago 20 years ago 10
years ago it's a hope that you have to
now think about say what does that mean
for my actions for what I do and how I
do it
most most chalking I was just reading an
article where is a conflict between
people who want to explore Mars and and
the people who who care about global
warming why would these people have a
conflict with each other how could that
even happen well the people who want to
explore Mars they want to take away
money from the people who are worried
about the global-warming who want to fix
the planet versus the ones who explore
Mars want to leave it just with some
roads so these are two competing ideas
now and you have to pick sides you have
to say well you either one of lever or
or a remainder
it's a crazy rope I didn't think of that
at all until just a few weeks ago when I
read this so so my first observation
here coming from from an engineering
background is that the law of
thermodynamics with entropy increasing
or staying the same in a static system
applies here it seems to me that that
from an individual perspective for me as
a human being the number of conflicts
that that I am part of that I that I see
around me that I'm participating in
seems to be increasing over time it
doesn't seem to be going away so the
number of conflicts we participate in
seems to be going up at the same time we
of course the law of conservation of
energy my energy is not increasing I
have the same amount of energy that I
had before and I have no way to increase
the amount of personal energy I have or
the amount of time I have what does that
mean it means that the amount of time
and energy that I have to deal with each
one
of these conflicts is going on right I
don't have time and energy to deal with
each one of them the same amount that I
had before because there's so many more
of them I have to worry about them where
where am i standing where do i position
itself inside of that so so it's getting
a lot more complicated there are some
some people have already pointed out to
me that sometimes conflicts get resolved
and that may be a unsupportive element
for my observation number one so now I
thought about that yes it's true some
conflicts get resolved so what do we do
with them when they get resolved
well we quickly write them into a book
and we give the book to our children to
read about them in school so that we
don't lose them so really hanging on our
conflict they're not teaching people or
children about great stuff that has
happened 100 years ago now we teach them
about conflict number one conflict
number two conflict number three and
they have to remember the years in which
each one of these conflicts happened and
who won right and depending on who wrote
the book of course there's a different
story
but we really don't want to give up on
conflicts even a thousand years after
they happen some people hold onto them
for for even longer so so there is there
is a discussion but but I'm still
holding on to the number even even if
they get resolved in some way here's an
interesting one um I was going to visit
a potential client to just show the kind
of perspective of you have this great
idea and you go to someone you tell them
about this great idea this was a night
capital group in New Jersey they were as
it says here the largest trader off of
something at some point in some way and
I went there and and we we told them
about a great idea a Killswitch a piece
of technology you put into the net
work and if you start losing money too
quickly from your trading if the money
goes down it makes mistakes then the
machine would simply cut the buy or stop
it so you don't keep sending these buy
and sell things so you kind of stop it
with time to fix it I thought that was
quite a good idea seemed like a really
important thing to do these were people
trading very quickly on the nanosecond
level so they really had a big risk of
something went wrong by the time you
figure it out it's already all gone so
we did have over a hundred people in the
audience and they all listened very
carefully and then the CTO came over to
me and he told us that we don't make any
mistakes I mean if you think we make
mistakes and then things happened that
could be because if we were to make
mistakes
he said we wouldn't be around today we
have clearly not made any mistakes in
the past this has never happened so
predicting that it would happen in the
future is based on on past history has
never happened before
so why would be predicted it could
happen in the in the future right so it
also says that and of course they are
seized to trade on July 1 2013 and so I
have my calendar entry here in 2012 and
and the end of the existence of that
organisation in 2013 which which is a
fantastic story where they had a bug in
their software and a software programmer
was told to fix the bug and he fixed the
bug and each acted in and they turned it
on again later all the money was gone
the bug fixed the problem but it also
had some other side effects that meant
that they lost all of their money within
a few seconds so the whole organisation
thousands of people just cease to exist
within one bug fix and there was of
course no kill switch there to to stop
it so so I thought that was quite
historic to add if we go back to to this
one yet another one of these I showed
these examples of of a great
accomplishment but I can also show them
as examples of conflict
so the
picture on the left is now quite a few
years ago and of course you can imagine
the number of conflicts that have arisen
from the two parties in in the picture
if you follow european boring european
politics there's also a conflict on the
right you see a Mack seller machine
standing next to an IBM Blue Gene and
the conflict on the right may may as
well have been a lot a lot more intense
than than the one on the left because it
was clearly a a tremendous mistake of
history that that a Mac seller machine
was ever allowed to sit next to an IBM
Blue Gene right there so so these are
conflicts and one doesn't think about I
wouldn't have thought about you know
where is my product going to sit and
who's going to be next to that and who
would be bothered by it no these are
real actual picture so so as part of all
of that the the amount of uncertainty
seems to be increasing the better we get
at predicting the future the more aiv
use that the more we learn about how we
can predict the future the more of the
future we are predicting away the less
predictable the future becomes because
we've already predicted away all the
stuff that can be easily predicted so
the side effect of getting better at
predicting the future is that it's
getting harder and harder and the future
is becoming more and more chaotic and
and we can see some of that in things
happening where you say wow you know I
wouldn't have thought that could happen
and more and more of these world events
where you think I would not have been
able to predict that one are happening
around us so for exact Kenan AI today
predict which company will be around a
year from now
more importantly if an AI was to predict
which company will not be around a year
from now what does that do
to the stock price of that company right
so so these are just questions I don't
have answers to this but I do have
another observation to add here which is
following from the efficient markets
theory so so the efficient markets
theory is is quite quite well known a
price is established by supply and
demand and and you have an efficiency in
there which which means that any
knowledge about the future is priced in
in the current price of of an asset
right and if you apply that to apply
that to my my idea here you can say that
because of a I predict the future the
future is getting more and more
unpredictable because the future gets
priced into our understanding it becomes
our our current present and if the
predictable future becomes our present
then there's only the unpredictable part
left as our actual future just
observations again no no hard proof
possible at this point yet but I'm now
taking that to the next level of saying
ok can be to apply that to something
useful to something that we all wanted
to do it's it's always a pleasure here
to speak at Stanford because the
audience in Stanford is is extremely
entrepreneurial and all the students
here are clearly going to want to start
their own business and so I thought
maybe sharing a little bit something
about how that looks like could be could
be quite useful and fun and so here is
how how I perceived the whole process is
going so you you go to school you're
given the problem you find the solution
the end we're done you get the grade
everything's fine if you had it right
everything is good right you had the
right answer the right solution you
solve the problem gets trained to solve
the problem what you don't do is you
never think about which conflicts would
be created by the solution that you've
suggested
that's beyond that that just has and so
nobody ever thinks about that we get
don't get trained to do it you don't get
taught there's no books about this there
is no way to learn how to do this and
yet it happens you have a pain point you
start a company you find the solution
you build a product you sell the product
you create all kind of conflicts with
that and they hit with you Wow I will
never thought that that would be a
problem because all of these conflicts
they all create a lot of pain points
again so you've started with one pain
point you end up with with many even
though you had the correct solution you
have you did everything right the the
product does address the problem that
that you you've addressed
um and then even worse even worse
because if you come from a technical
background like technical stuff you
solve technical problems you pick a
technical pain point you solve the
technical pain point what do you get in
return you get non-technical pain points
back see somebody doesn't like it it's
like yeah but it's the right answer
technically it works the fact that
somebody likes it or doesn't like it is
not a technical problem right there's no
course that that I know of that would
prepare you for that or help you with
that to think about it even even less
and that would let you put it because
one of the things you would to do is you
would need to predict what that conflict
is that that your solution is going to
create and that's even worse because
that that's way beyond so so I thought
of of it from an engineering perspective
of course I see a state machine in
everything in everything I do state
machines are great because they're
they're understandable from an
engineering perspective so here we have
the started company state machine where
you start with a pain point you're told
in in lean product development you start
with the pain point you find your
solution you build the product you sell
the product you make some money great
you did that
it's a steak machine what happens is
after you sell the product you're
creating conflict you may be creating
technical pain points commercial pain
points social pain points or legal pain
points you may not know much about these
different topics when you get started at
the beginning because you picked your
own pain point is something that you
really like but many many technical
solutions end up with a legal issue that
they haven't thought of and they have to
backtrack because they don't know how to
solve that one or a social social issue
where a commercial issue so so when you
do a product plan you need to identify
the pain point in to identify the
conflicts caused by the solution that
you have and then identify the new pain
points that arise as a result of that
and the speed at which you can do that
determines if your state machine is
stable or unstable because that state
machine also has a halt condition as we
know all state machines on some state
machines have hold conditions this one
has a halt condition which is money it
goes down to zero so if the state of
your new enterprise is the bank account
and the total amount of money you have
in there at the point when the money
goes to zero the state machine stops
just halt finished doesn't do anything
anymore
so so I found that quite interesting
because it really looks like this right
you sell the product you create the
conflict you create you find the pain
points you find solutions to these pain
points you may be really diligent and
find the solution but that just creates
a whole other range of conflict so as
you started with what pain point it
grows quite quite dramatically and if
you don't start preparing for this early
solving that one first pain point is
irrelevant you're going to find the
solutions to these extreme problems that
you've just created right if you can do
that then it's worthwhile to start
solving the first one which is easy
anybody could have done
that like it's just one and its
technical and and if you go to to a good
school or you study hard to learn you
know how to do things you can learn how
to solve a technical problem the other
ones are much less termina sztyc so that
going back to to my endeavor of having
built really really fast computers
that's great it worked we build it you
turn it on it does exactly what I said
it would do fantastic
here's a list of conflicts it created on
the first round so that's not a few
that's quite a bit so so we ran into
lots and lots of issues one was well of
course we started with saying creating
circuits is hard designing circuits is
hard let's create a high level language
to do that
and we've done that it made it really
really easy to program these machines
but then we figure out well ah there's a
site problem which is when you buy the
trip from the company you need to
connect memory to it because just
computing is not enough it needs to come
memory and if that memory comes memory
interface connection to this memory and
turns out that the company that makes
FPGA doesn't have as fast connections to
memory as CPUs and GPUs have so you
start off with very slow connection to
memory so that's that's not good you
gotta solve that that's that's an actor
there is photic point which now doesn't
work very well on these on these
machines okay so if that doesn't work
very well
don't do something that goes into a
fixed point or or some other number
representation now you have to study
number representation between on numerix
there's a solution to that one we have
two separate CPUs and fps but you may
need some of this and some of that but
you don't know how many of each you need
in each instance so putting them
together means that that you're
inefficient in the resource sharing
application it would steal the source
code from the person who's written it or
from the person who owns it carve it out
of their dead fingers who are holding on
to this to not give it away and take it
and then change it and give it back to
them changed which they won't want to
have debugging the thing afterwards
really hard how do you do buggy circuits
is not a software thing there's no way
to step through it we're going to do it
just kind of dozen then it's wrong so so
debugging it really really difficult you
need a whole other thing
and then then you're left if the
compiler just compile it yes you compile
it but when you compile it it takes
three days
what well it takes three days to compile
the program to actually get the circuit
out and that's where people stop and sit
wait what who where three days where you
push compile and then what you're going
to do well you wait for three days until
the software is actually mapped the
thing on Turkey didn't put it into the
chip that's a really really big conflict
cause because on the other side I'm just
compiling and pushing the button it
compels in a few minutes now there is a
problem which is that the people who
know how to write these circuits are at
the end of the day if you do solve all
of these are out of a job that that
causes unhappiness even if everything
works and even if you've resolved all of
these but then there is a time even most
annoying problem which is that most
software doesn't need to run any faster
or it can be easily fixed in some other
way so the necessity of running
computers faster is not always given so
there's there's solutions to these
things I'll walk you through quickly we
have a programming environment there's a
university program over 150 universities
in the world are using this for playing
around with creating circuits there's
publications for over a decade on doing
these things it's a dual representation
inspired by by professor morph here who
taught me about dual representations and
drawing the graphs to the text and and
doing that together lots of fun for the
adventurous programmer we have another
another fun thing where we can connect
the area of the chip to the actual Java
program you're right so your Java
program and it annotates for each line
of code how much space it's going to
take on the chip so connecting space and
time which is a fun tool and so we have
many many of these you can annotate it
also with time so you could say this
number of nanoseconds for this line that
number of nanoseconds for the other line
so you can both optimize nanosecond
latency for a computation as well as the
space it is taking on the chip by
looking at the different Java statements
very very high level statements of a
flow of data so this is solving the the
idea of of making it easier to program
in that space the memory interfaces what
do you do well there's four solutions we
found on the memory interface is it
slower okay fine but there is a memory
on the chip and that memory has more
than ten terabytes per second bandwidth
up let's use that one but it's smaller
okay so you need to partition your
application into smaller pieces that fit
in the ten megabytes or 20 megabytes
that you have in the chip and then you
use ten terabytes per second which is a
lot faster than any other technology out
there for accessing memory so so you can
do that you can also build cards with a
lot more of that memory on it turns out
these faster memories also cause a lot
of problems electrically in terms of
cooling it and space and all of that so
we were able to put 96 gigabytes of DRAM
onto a little card that was half the
size of the GPU card that had eight
gigabytes at a time okay so so you can
hold bigger problem sizes of course then
we would say about we can solve problems
that are much bigger than the GPUs
because if your problem fits into 96
gigabytes
it's a homerun compared to
which have to talk to all kinds of other
cards and you have inter card
communication of course then people
would say fine but I'll just I'll just
compute the small problem maybe I don't
need the bigger one it's not not so
urgent you have new things coming out a
chronics is a smaller fpga company now
coming out with a fantastic technology
including g DDR six which is the memory
technology that the GPUs have so you can
now get get that combined which was not
available for many years and and of
course Xilinx also has a solution to
this which is the
metrical one which is to use HBM you
have a package and you put the DRAM into
the same package together with the FPGA
so now you have a theorem in the same
package ultra-fast very very efficient
really really nice solution to this
problem
so there are solutions to this technical
solutions for floating-point we
redeveloped the whole idea of
computation around different bit widths
so every variable in your program could
have a different number of bits to
represent it and so we have a numeric
stool that it lets you plot and analyze
and understand the numerical behavior of
each one of your variables turns out
some people get offended when you tell
them that a variable has a statistical
distribution of values that it takes
across the lifetime of of the program
running because there is no science
behind that there is no math that can
explain to you what that means because
in math of course all variables have
infinite precision and are always
perfectly accurate and the solution to
the numerix problem is to make
everything a double precision floating
point close your eyes cross your fingers
and hope for the best
right that's that's the mathematician
solution the physicist is curiously
interested in the topic
but doesn't have any mathematical tools
to study them at all because the fact
that they variable would have a finite
precision doesn't have a mathematical
theory behind it so graphically it works
and so we have a tool and you can look
at it and you can study the statistics
and how many bits are needed
separating FPGAs from CPUs we had to
build our own machines only build a box
which has FPGAs in them connected in a
band and now you have the refugees
outside of the CPU what does that mean
it means that the computation moves away
from your CPU into the other box that
doesn't have the CPUs now that creates
an obvious conflict with server vendors
who say about we sell CPU servers you're
saying you're taking away the
computation from our box and you're
putting it in your box that's out of
question I mean you can't possibly say
that that's what you're going to do
we'll do the computation in the box you
may be able to to send a little bit of
stuff across the PCI Express bus to
something else but you can take the
whole computation out and put it in the
other box I mean that that's just other
question right commercially that would
mean that you lose the computation to
this other box another conflict in
towards a strange one which is that used
InfiniBand which is a networking
protocol to connect cables you go to a
bank you say we have this thing and it
does this you see ok I'll get one and it
connects these boxes with infinities
what InfiniBand no no no you can't have
that
InfiniBand is forbidden in banking data
centers see what you have a rule against
in networking standard in a data center
especially the fastest one that is out
there why would you do that of course
you can't get any answers to these
questions but we say okay fine fine time
they'll rename it well we name it we'll
say this is a max salary
the answer to binary coded decimal in
bangs is yes but exclusively on IBM
mainframes which are powered by cobble
so it would not be done in any other
programming language so it's only COBOL
and only on IBM mainframes but yes
our world still lives on on IBM
mainframes and COBOL in fact possibly
all of our bank accounts are stored on
an IBM mainframe in COBOL okay well I'm
sure they are because nobody would dare
touch any assembly language that's right
yes yes I'm sure there is no there's
always exception I'm not saying all of
it but big big amounts there was no
software so we created this software
store a software gallery for for FPGAs
you have a nice number of applications
on there need to rewrite parts of the
application well okay fine so so we
developed a corporate process of
rewriting software of analyzing it
figuring out which parts to rewrite and
teaching people how to do that as a new
conflict created there because we're
changing the code which is maintained by
someone which is now only compatible
with a proprietary third-party tool on
proprietary third-party hardware so turn
turned out people don't like that I was
kind of but then Nvidia came along and
convinced the world that it is okay to
rewrite parts of your application in
CUDA and after people started rewriting
things included that argument went away
it was ok to rewrite things because
they've just done it for CUDA so it's
possible so so that was solved by by
that activity and of course there are
some automatic compilation things like
like there is a big stream nowaday that
that offers automatic use of FPGAs for
for standard software packages
FPGA debugging is hard so we have
debuggers that check where the numbers
are how they flow through the system
what happens to them so you get
visibility into the hardware as it is
computing and that helps with debug that
has of course issues also on efficiency
so this is a tool that shows events
across multiple nodes multiple trips
multiple activities and they want to be
able to overlap and balance computation
across multiple chips CPUs FPGAs others
and so there is the tool to do that and
there is one looks at performance
between different kernels on the chip
how the data moves and and helps us to
debug performance issues if it doesn't
run this fastest as it should then then
you can monitor that with with something
that shows you the runtimes of the
different kernels but we still have the
problem of place in route taking three
days we're going to do about that well
we thought first let's build a large
cluster of machines and and have a job
distribution system for these compiled
jobs and so we build large amounts of
infrastructure tools and hardware to do
these compiled jobs and that meant we
have to have a loop data center in the
office that you have to play with fair
enough then we said ok fine maybe we
could go to the FPGA vendors and tell
them this is a problem because they
maybe they haven't thought of it
so say well I take the source code for
for place in route and we accelerated on
the FPGA s and all the conflicts I have
mentioned so far in this talk are
nothing compared to the conflict that
has been created with that suggestion
because of course the software for place
in route is the holy grail of the FPGA
community and they would never ever let
anybody touch it
let alone put it onto an FPGA that would
be completely outrageous and unheard of
so didn't get anywhere with that one but
there is another solution as well which
which could help not that we made any
progress on that but one could change
the architecture of the chip as well
to be easier to to route if one gets rid
of the timing closure problem so you
just put in the flip-flops you run into
the fixed up frequency you would solve
it as well but again that that's a
bigger solution out there finally how
how do we help people who really like
hardware descriptions well we gave up
after after a decade and a half of
trying to convince people that they
shouldn't be wasting their time writing
circuits on the RTL level we now have a
solution for it you can just use our
tools to generate IP cores in RTL and
then you can use it that you don't need
to tell anyone that you've used our
tools to generate it and then if you can
generate something with our tools in the
day that would take you a month or a
year to write in RTL that that should
have some some benefits so there's now a
way to interface between hardware
activities and the tools that yeah we
also have a way to import these IP
course if you write your own HDL bit and
you say I'm happy to use the new tools
but I have this thing I wrote ten years
ago and I really can't give up on it
this is my favorite circuit I don't
never be able to do anything we found it
you can now import it into into this
system as well finally one of the
annoying ones most software doesn't need
to be accelerated with special hardware
here is an example of a proper
production code used for regulatory
reporting which is very important this
is when you report the government
something that is legally required for
you to report to them in a timely manner
and they said all this has to be
reported in a fixed amount of time you
have eight hours from the request to
report it and this thing would run for
three days so so they said wow you could
have built some special hardware to do
this we looked at it it was an SQL
script they said but this SQL script is
really fast I mean this is an SQL script
that by the world's leading vendor of
databases has been made to run as fast
as possible and
you have the fastest double-aught it in
Python and it ran 119 times faster so
special hardware is not always necessary
a little bit of of proper knowledge of
computer system helps as well to to
solve many many of them of the world but
again it's something that comes out of
it to explain it they they didn't
believe it so so I had we had an analogy
to explain it I Drive a Prius when I go
to the airport and I said well the
equivalent if you think the Python is me
driving to the airport in the Prius this
is what you're doing trying to get to
the airport right and so this is 120
times speed difference and it doesn't
have any space for for the suitcase so
that would be an additional problem so
then you would think okay we've solved
most of these problems but now we have
second generation problems what are the
second generation problem so the second
generation problems is that if one rack
off of FPGAs replaces 10 racks of CPUs
CPU vendors are selling 10 times less
that's a real problem
they've already predicted selling the
CPUs forward for the next 10 years
didn't want to sell less wanna sell more
CPUs so if the software could be made to
run slower that we much better you could
sell more CPUs and and we don't they
don't of course have any examples where
we're slower software is being put into
advantageous positions to achieve that
now we build a cybersecurity product
around this as well they said ok you
could build a firewall that 10 times 20
times smaller faster and more secure
than a half a rack off of commercial
data center firewall today they said yes
that's great but there's a commercial
problem
CEL I don't know let's say if you sell a
thousand boxes at 1 million that's a
billion dollars if I can now reduce the
cost of the box two hundred thousand
you're now only getting ten million
right but while you were getting a
builder or 100 billion while you were
getting really well you get a billion
before so so it causes just a drop in in
revenue right there because it is
cheaper and faster right so cheaper and
faster has real impact on on commercial
reality of companies and even if they
could they wouldn't do it because it
makes no sense to destroy your market
where people are willing to pay a
million to tell the nominal you can have
it for for a hundred thousand it's fine
that doesn't make any sense commercial
if it is computation by ten times then
the data coming out of that hits your
infrastructure at ten times the speed
now you have to change all of your
infrastructure to be able to deal with
data coming at you at ten times the
speed if the result of your computation
is hitting a team of ten people who has
to read what the computation did and do
something with it if you accelerate the
computation by ten times now the team of
ten people has to be a team of hundred
people because you need ten times more
people to read the stuff that came out
of the computation and you could imagine
other types of infrastructure but the
impact on the whole infrastructure can
be catastrophic if the FPGA solution
means changing vendor then of course the
stability of your supply chain might
might be rocked you might have
relationships in place with a supply
chain that that goes all around the
world and because of one purchase of one
computer now your supply doesn't work
anymore because it cuts across the
supply chain so you have to align with
supply chains of
if if computing marriages FPGAs printing
language because the social problem
maybe some people just don't like it
see we don't just don't like Java not a
nice language we only use this other
thing and then then of course there is a
regulatory problem if your computation
uses a different type of arithmetic you
have qualified over a painstaking ten
year process you've qualified a piece of
code to be compliant with government
requirements and you've convinced the
government to accept your computation as
a fair computation to report to them
you've changed the arithmetic model to
start again try explaining to them how
that works alright take another ten
years who would want to do that so these
are all generation problems and my
conclusion here is really that the
important thing is to think about the
cycle to think about the title of pain
point solution conflict which drives
things in a circle and and spend more
time enumerated and understanding these
conflicts than actually solving them
because if you just focus on solving
them every time you solve one you just
create a lot more of them so solving
less and analyzing the conflicts more
seems seems to me at least to be a
winning starting point even though I
don't have an answer to to to all the
challenges posed here it's just again an
observation that I had and I I thought
I'll share that and that's the end of my
talk thank you very much likes products
going to China how can you continue your
project was seeing why I don't know I
have no idea okay so so the way okay so
just to explain there is a webpage from
the State Department
which lays out on a day-by-day basis
what US corporations are allowed and are
not allowed to do and you simply log on
to the web page once a day you look at
what you're allowed to do what you're
not allowed to do and you do that and
then you're okay right
oh you're fine tomorrow we do whatever
it says okay so just a related thing it
seems to me research inherently creates
pain points in fact you could say it's
the job to research to create a point
because now you have to cope with these
new discoveries and these new
developments like right now we have this
huge pain point in intelligent systems
that the research community has gotten
way out of head okay of what the
companies and the defense laboratories
are doing right and so you worry about
that because that creates a huge gap and
somebody else might exploit it yes I my
point is to not worry about it but to
collect it I find that there is a
uncomfortableness in talking about
conflict people don't want to talk about
confident to avoid conflict want to
resolve conflict but they don't want to
make a list of all the conflicts
possible that that could happen that is
very socially unattractive and I believe
we need to step out of that and take on
these conflicts and write them down in a
impartial way not taking sides not
trying to resolve them too quickly but
to collect them and think deeply about
what all the different conflicts could
be so that they don't come as a surprise
afterwards supposed to prevent surprise
in the US okay
so in companies SEC filings they have
lots of risks
do you think those kinds of risks are
related somehow to the conflicts that
you're talking about that come out of
technical solutions
I think risk is different I think we
have a good handle on risk management we
have a chief risk officer in most large
corporations and I think we are we are
dealing with risk in many many different
ways there are professionals who deal
with risk and I find it is slightly
different than conflict because conflict
is not so much a risk as it is a status
of things it's not about what would
happen but just the fact it's more about
maybe it's about what will not happen
rather than what will happen risk is
about the thing that would happen as a
consequence of what you've done
while conflict is about the things that
will not happen is it consequence maybe
maybe that's an answer I don't know but
it's definitely different
maybe risk is a probability of something
happening whereas conflict is the thing
which might happen or might not happen
that could also be could be
probabilistic versus binary absolutely I
don't know yeah it's a it's an
interesting question
Oscar yes so you describe these problems
and conflicts as if you someone as I saw
them all themselves in fact entropy
entropy you know but they're like new
smart people coming into the system and
sort of the you know the amount of
energy isn't to bring to bear on these
problems it's not really yes it is total
as a society we have more and more
people to tackle more and more
that's why I said my perspective is
purely from an individual's perspective
yeah but I know but that's there this uh
a proverb that says if you want to go
fast go alone but if you want to go far
go with the team so it seems that this
is a challenge for a diverse team yes of
people to attack and that's part of the
initial problem is putting together this
team with people to attack this complex
problem but in order to put together the
diverse team of people you need to be
anticipating the type of conflicts that
you might be getting in the future to
have a team that can address these so I
fully agree a team can help and it's not
just the addressing I think the key is
the speed at which you're addressing
them because you have to address them at
the faster speed than they're coming at
you and the difference between a company
that can scale up versus a company that
stays flat or goes down is really the
speed at which all of these different
conflicts get resolved so absolutely in
a global sense you can look at it as a
team of people resolving that in from an
individual's perspective even if you
have a team of people if the number of
conflicts you're personally involved in
is increasing you need to deal with more
and more of them so you can't just
increase the number of people you're
talking to because there's a limit to
how many people you can talk to in the
day so so there is a a momentum balance
kind of thing going on where you need to
deal with the conflicts faster than
you're generating them another question
thank you so it sounds like one of the
assumptions that we have is that as we
solve pain points
we tend to generate them exponentially
but it seems like one of the other I
guess halting solutions and those in the
state that you put up in one of the
sides would be if we can find some way
of reducing the number of conflicts that
are generated when we solve one I said
do you have any tips for that or what
are your thoughts on that well in order
to reduce the number of pain points that
we are creating we need to be able to
think a few moves ahead what I'm
suggesting is that the chess player
always thinks many moves ahead and has a
tree of possibilities that they're going
through but you make a move and then you
have to anticipate the other side's move
and anticipate the other side's move if
you read a book on product development
it does not do that it does not go two
or three steps out and so that is what
we have to develop we have to develop a
a methodology to think several steps
ahead and be able to to think about how
that we want is getting harder and
harder because as I was suggesting
predicting gets harder and harder but
that's exactly what we need to do we
need to predict the things that we will
be create in order to create less right
you need to be able to first predict
what will create so you have three
solutions you could go for you need to
be able to predict how many conflicts
each one of these solutions would create
rather than just pick the one solution
that is the least amount of work which
is the one that always gets picked right
and the least amount of work may lead to
most conflicts later on but if you don't
think so
thinking several steps forward in the
cycle drawing it as a cycle is the
starting point rather than a two step
process where you say you have a pain
point of a solution you're done you need
to think about the consequences and the
consequences of these consequences and
then the value at the options based on
that I think that that's my suggestion
okay can you explain how we can
incorporate machine learning and the
blockchain into this project
I think we're running out of time master
thank you very much
[Applause]